The Joe Rogan experience.
Zero alcohol.
Let's get crazy.
Let's pace ourselves.
She takes cheers,
sir.
I'm gonna Chug this.
Whoa.
Don't deny any of that.
Sweet,
dangerous.
Zero alcohol.
How many calories though?
We scared cow horse,
Bro.
Tell you stay alive.
That's going to get your energy back there.
Plenty of calories already.
I have to ask you.
Did you drive it in the Hemi?
No,
I didn't.
I got dropped off in a Chevy.
Oh my God.
This is outrageous.
I had one for a little while.
Just a little while.
Figured like you would have to have one for quite a long time.
It was fun.
Well,
okay,
I'm going to backtrack a little day.
So first commercial,
right,
that,
thank God I hear me right.
I did six of these things and around commercial three,
I,
uh,
I was talking to my agent and I said,
man,
you know,
if they asked you to do another one,
oh shit.
Here we go.
Yeah.
My God,
that's the worst I've ever looked at my life.
I really felt like I was sitting in the desert like no one's ever going to see
these commercials.
That wasn't going to know what a Hammy is incorrect.
I could not have been more wrong.
Yeah,
yeah.
There it is.
Look at that bad ass.
Did they give you one or did you just go out and buy one?
Well,
I said,
listen,
if they,
if they want me to do another commercial,
see if you can get a vehicle out of them.
Right in.
My agent was like,
you know,
make it their problem.
He calls him up.
He goes,
hey,
I don't know if you know this,
but your [inaudible] guy,
your spokesman is driving around Los Angeles right now on a Suzuki sidekick.
Oh.
And they're like,
hey,
miss.
I found out the fucking,
the CMOS,
so at the same thing,
it's the lightest.
It's a box.
Skype.
If you could put a string to it and float in the air.
That shitty looking jeep thing.
Yes.
Oh Wow.
You have one of those?
I did,
yeah.
Red.
Wow.
I don't know why.
For some reason I liked that thing.
I got it in college and as the way I like it.
Yeah.
This college,
it was cool for a tailgating and shit.
There it is.
Yeah,
I did that.
That's the ll cool j versus how did they have that one?
Let's say I include J.
Dot.
No,
I think I saw that a video one though.
Cause it's a cause that's the one I had,
right.
You've got the hard top.
Damn.
Yeah.
I had total that thing in North Dakota one time hit black eyes.
[inaudible] Augusta wind just knocked me off the road and I was in a ditch,
but it was uh,
you know how people in motorcycles,
they'll see another motorcycle and they'll wave.
It's like a little club that you're in and jeeps do it too.
And I started doing that to other Suzuki sidekicks and out of port for a reason,
I'd wave to him nine times out of 10.
It's like a overweight black lady.
And then I just went with that and I'm like,
what is he doing with it?
I was like,
what the club man.
So,
but yeah,
uh,
people like got hit me ice cars.
Yeah.
But to do that with shitty cars too.
That's what he does next level.
That's more fun.
Yeah.
Like I see you,
did they give you when they give you him?
Uh,
it was a,
uh,
1500 dodge ram quad cab.
The lack,
a lot of chrome feel comfortable in it.
I loved it.
I lived when I first got it.
You know,
it's like,
it's like the,
in the middle of,
you know,
I did six of those commercials.
So as rod around La with the windows down just blasting,
you know,
Leonard Skinner did shit.
Yeah.
That's perfect.
The comedy store and like park it,
I made,
they hated parking that thing in that,
in that light,
because it's gigantic.
Yeah.
That's a wide,
and they're like really mad.
Can you just have somebody drop you off?
Yeah.
Brendan Chavs but showing up in his,
uh,
he got a raptor.
Oh yeah.
We realized how wide those things are until you're standing in front of him.
Like,
like huge Fox does that fucking giant vehicle.
And then trying to valet that thing anywhere in Los Angeles,
you know,
that's a lot of tiny little Mexican dudes are like,
really,
man.